hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7 now
this sounds you're hearing are the
sounds of war apparently and war that I
need to fight for some reason I don't
know what is going on in Jack's head now
that he's a horrible monstrosity but you
know he was kind of a horrible hey hey
hey hey hey hey I could really use a
bomb at this point but I don't have the
means Wow well ow
I don't do I have the means no I don't
I'm gonna go run for it you know I don't
have the space to fight right now so I'm
just gonna and I go over here go this
medicine go into the woods here circle
around okay what's going on over here
where am I going now what the hell oh hi
oh yes it's a super hitting fist of
course you know of course left good old
good old the hit II ah
hitties been upgraded to punchy now I
got punchy and 50 here
[Laughter]
run your dick run your dick
this is the greatest thing you charge it
up oh wow this tea is fishy is raring to
go alright well that I am dumb time oh
man I think I should aptly named my new
lefty into fisty again because fisty
fishy seems to have another purpose i
mean i don't want to call a spade a
spade but that vibration that's very
[Music]
interested that i'm laughing at the
music about other musics are like
frickin like Avengers music is
unbelievably powerful Joe Wow okay
you're already thinking about putting
them down not like you know rescue him
or try to save him or some something
like that no Jackie boys just got to go
you know what it's fine I get it I get
it
I remember this area this was a
Marguerite's house area oh that's sad oh
so we made this I didn't I didn't see
this before all that's sweet okay well
okay well that's sad Jesus man this game
is so hilarious
and I know you know that the developer
knows that it's hilarious the developer
knows it like it's it's also obviously
just like the music I think proves it
because the music that's his way to hype
and to do royalty-free sounding to not
be like a a conscious choice of
ridiculousness alright oh no I can't get
through oh like it's already open okay
alright then
stupid puzzles always causing a ruckus
oh hey I'm eating Marguerite's bugs
this is hot guess gross very gross yeah
wait
that's okay alright then can you you can
stop any time now though Jews
alright oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah that's a
good stuff whoo awesome hi what happens
a video a partial Oh still good oh oh oh
oh boy I love this you're still alive
what I guess it wasn't a full charge
might as well just have been a normal
punch at that point I guess oh come on I
want to go those ways now why didn't
they just burn all this down whoa
charging stop right in your leg stop run
your ass stop right in your face hey
friend
whap I love it and why can't I go
through there I even see the doorway
down there oh come on
alright fine y'all hype bastards let's
see what you got come on I'm ready for
you Oh [ __ ] guy alright wait I got a
sunburn you want me to come to you
alright
oh he's dead oh he's dead oh it's very
dead
[Music]
you think the combos still work now I
mean not that anything's gonna survive
long oh yeah oh yeah champion effigy oh
god I love this fist ah called super
fisty all right oh yeah this is lovely
man it's been a while but since I've
been over to the Baker residence just
just a little bit just a little while
you know he's gotta be got a boo you up
way out okay well alright then hello
uh-oh somebody got rekt hello hello or
maybe maybe Joe has been infected like
the whole time too maybe I I honestly
don't know I don't know how he could
just not know about all this that's
weird okay I'll go there eventually do
you have to ask Joe do you have to ask
alright lost inventory has been moved to
the item box okay that's weird
oh that's right when I went down the
river I guess I got piggy lost all my
[ __ ] my bombs my balls please oh boy
here we go
all my effigies oh yes gimme gimme gimme
gimme
okay alright so I need to make I can't
make anything except chem fluid but I
don't need more of that or group juice
but I can't do anything more
we finished analyzing the tissue samples
believed to be from Jack Baker the cells
exhibited extraordinary resilience to
physical and chemical damage to the
e-series muta my seed secretes a
telomerase like enzyme through the cell
wall causing abnormal activision of the
ER k pathway to achieve forced cell
division quickly regenerating damaged
tissue
however the repeated cell division
quickly leads to breakdown of the
intercellular structure leading to the
sloughing slurry like effect we've
observed in the collected soot tissue
samples our working hypothesis puts this
down to the cells reaching their
hayflick limit
note that the samples from the other
family members of the wife Marguerite
and son Lucas and daughter Zoey do not
exhibit the same extreme regenerative
properties the symptoms may differ from
subject to subject further study is
required
fancy Oh Steve Steve what are you doing
in what are you doing in Steve what are
you doing in Steve aah you carry on
Steve you have a good one Steve
see you around the bend I'm gonna say it
one more time because I'm crazy like
that
all right see it Steve hey buddy all
right you have a go watch Dave all right
later
later Gator all right what do we got
here can I go down there no man it's
been a while since I beg them back in
here oh so cool I love it I love it I
love it all right come on Jack time for
a final showdown
mmm I don't know is her father
Noah I guess he's just trying to take
her home weird Zoe hey Jack all right
miss me come out now
oh my super punches and I'm not even
gonna do it really with super punches I
am oh oh yeah look gives you small
better way
come on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Oh gonna punch around your ass I know
your weak spot Dex come on show me out
now don't do that Jack don't do that
Jack come on come on don't be like that
Jack oh oh yeah
you made your first mistake oh come on
come on come on oh yeah
ah goddamnit whoa duck Oh baby
we're handles yeah I want to see what
soon whoa whoa never cut never cut never
will yeah what you gonna do about it
oh yeah jack oh [ __ ] let me not just cuz
I got a superfish don't mean I'm
cheating I'm not meant to duck
I meant to duck
come on come on come on oh look me in
the eye jack okay oh [ __ ] no hey Zoey I
got caught up in my rage you are you
dead oh she's not there okay you are not
there
all right well didn't even need this
xrail Zoey Zoey you all right put on
some clothes damn it there you go
no Zoey why are you naked Zoey
oh now Jose all scared weapons down it's
all right you must be Zoe Baker Chris
Redfield
I've been looking all over for you we're
here to help
she's still covered in goop I guess
that's a better alternative she would be
naked if that goop went away and nobody
nobody wants that Oh
BLAP BLAP right in your neck just like
Zach from Zach Phil especially we found
her he's a tough kid
of course Oh God someone wants to speak
to you who is it mr. umbrella Zoe is
Ethan don't believe it you actually made
it we both did
you didn't forget about me I told you
I'd send help
and I always keep my promises
thank you well I mean he did kind of
throw you to the wolves first off the
bat but hey it's a happy ending yeah all
right now I know I know I know this is
the end here and this is awesome I love
this DLC this was so fun like just from
a pure fun standpoint it was so fun
but what I got to do I got to see if
there is like an unlimited battle arena
mode with Joe because God the punching
mechanic is so fun
punches 620 oh it's so fun extreme
challenges complete all to obtain the
spirit blow challenging tails can be
found in the stats from the pause menu
Joe must say yes oh that's just a
difficulty us [ __ ] weapon mg 7 8 a-m 21
shotgun we're gonna go Joe must die oh
cassette tapes are required autosave
frequency has been reduced oh hell yeah
hang on I'm not gonna do a full
playthrough the game again but alright
gonna skip this movie skip skip skip
skip I just got to get oh hi what are
you doing there
now oh this is this is a difficult whoa
they get him quick now there we go
boom okay all right well then that was
difficult okay hang on everybody hold on
hold on your ads Oh a throwing knife
wait what throwing knife when the hell
did what what has it always been there
did I not get that oh oh wow what the
hell this is this has changed
dramatically I need a cassette tape to
save Wow okay all right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there we go oh yeah oh the ticky ticky
bommie wah me boxes okay all right well
well if that's the way you're gonna do
it then I am NOT gonna play your game oh
boy yeah Wow
okay they weren't joking about this this
is this is gonna be difficult
oh oh they spotted me Wow okay that
doesn't finish him off okay oh yeah this
is gonna be a bit more tough oh yeah oh
man that already put me on the edge
how am i dying
oh okay Wow alright so that is toughest
[ __ ] man I don't know man I don't know
man
oh wow okay I have an idea okay aim for
the head actually apparently war just
stand for that yeah whoa okay I need to
do this hey and waffle stomp
alright did I get you
yeah no yeah I got you okay there we go
okay so now I kind of gotcha okay so I'm
gonna just press forward a little bit
because this is hard as hell holy [ __ ]
this is hard oh wow
okay that would have been death yeah man
they set this up definitely to screw
with me oh that didn't sound good
okay well I'm a run now oh no it's no
not one of those guys I hate those guys
I don't have health for this well there
I go okay that is freaking difficult but
that's a fun I'm not gonna keep trying
with that that's a fun mode though I
think that would be a fun challenge to
do so I think that ends it for Resident
Evil's new DLC it was super super fun I
hope they come out with more stuff I
hope to see a Resident Evil 8 like
there's so many cool things like the
Ethan must die stuff like the Joe must
die stuff like that is fun fun fun
really really well done and I just love
it like even this not a hero that was
fun it really was this was more the same
but this was something special end of
Zoe I love that so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down the comments below and
as always see you in the next video
[Music]